what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and I said I would do
another strength video if there shanks
video got over 4,000 likes and at the
time of writing it already got over 6000
likes that's amazing so here I am back
at it again with one of my favorite
one-piece characters the ever cool
dracool me Hawk if you enjoy seeing one
piece videos on this channel I want to
keep them coming
show some love for one piece by smashing
that like button and sharing this video
if we can get 5000 that's right
5000 likes on this video I'll get
started on the next strength video ASAP
make sure to leave your suggestions for
who you want me to cover next in the
comment if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future one-piece videos you can
follow anime up or audio on Spotify and
Apple podcasts or wherever else you
listen to podcasts to get early access
to all of our content including one
piece links in the description
keep in mind the way I do these videos
is I look at relevant manga evidence to
help get a sense of how strong the
character in question is so there tend
to be manga spoilers in these videos
you've been warned now without further
ado let's jump into it
dracool hawk eyes meet hawk is
introduced as the greatest swordsman in
the world in the veg translation and in
other translations he's been called the
strongest swordsman in the world in
other words he stands atop all other
swordsmen we'll talk more about the
significance of this title later me Hawk
was 41 years old before the time skip
and he's 43 years old after the time
skip he's 6 feet 6 inches tall dracool
actually holds the position that Zorro
strives to reach me Hawk is tzur oh what
gol D Roger is 2 Luffy except in me
Hawks case he's a living legend when me
Hawk is introduced he's introduced as
the guy who sunk 50 ships
single-handedly for fun he is able to
effortlessly destroy a galleon aka huge
warship with a sword me Hawk is able to
easily deflect bullets with his sword as
well at this point in the series
Zorro seems like a very strong dude but
he's absolutely no match for me Hawk me
Hawk even tells him that a competent
swordsman could tell that me hawk skills
for
surpass zoro's there's no need for them
to even cross swords mihawk already
knows how crushing me Hawks main problem
is boredom he's so strong that he can't
find a good challenge so he goes around
destroying the pirate ships for fun like
don krieg he's so strong that don krieg
accuses him of having a devil fruit
although as far as we know mihawk is
just Opie based solely on his own
strength no devil fruit to speak up
which is impressive because he surpasses
the vast majority of devil fruit users
and strength it's funny don krieg had 50
ships and he couldn't last in the grand
line while mihawk just goes around in a
tiny little boat by himself that's how
confident he is looking back on the
series it's clear that there are many
dangerous figures and crews you can run
into on the sea including the yonk oh
and yet me Hawk is confident enough to
travel like this it goes to show how
confident he is in his own ability to
take care of himself even against the
strongest of opponents against oro
mihawk starts off with using a small
knife saying to Zorro that he's not the
kind of fool who hunts rabbits with a
cannon he even apologized the saying
that that's the smallest knife he's got
in other words if he had a smaller
weapon he'd use it that's how a head of
Zorro he is here we could just say me
Hawk is arrogant but me Hawk has always
backed up his words he goes on to beat
Zorro's three swords with that little
knife me Hawk decides to use his real
sword not because he needs to but to
show respect for Zorro who would rather
die than give up me Hawk also refers to
his own black blade as the finest in the
world
Miha could kill Zorro easily but he sees
potential in him me Hawk would rather
give Thoreau a chance to try to surpass
him because he wants a challenge that's
when you know you're strong when you
genuinely hope that one day someone will
be able to surpass you we don't see me
hawk again until he goes to see the
yong-chol shanks remember me Hawk is a
warlord at this time so he should in
theory be going after pirates but that's
not actually how me hawk rolls he does
what he wants takes naps when he wants
destroys 50 ships when he wants and goes
to see old friends when he wants he
tells the man he runs into on the island
to relax and asks them to send him
straight to shanks
it is this encounter that sparks a lot
of heated debate in the one-piece
community shanks asks if me Hawk is
there to challenge him and me Hawk
replies by saying he doesn't challenge
one-armed has bends shanks nor his crew
members questioned me Hawk or say that
me Hawk wouldn't stand a chance against
shanks obviously this could just be how
shanks and his crew roll they don't care
too much about other people's opinions
like when the one mountain bandit
spilled beer on shanks and they just
laughed it off still though me Hawk does
hold the title of number one swordsman
and shanks is a swordsman so yes me Hawk
calling a young Co has been is clearly
going overboard and straying from cold
hard facts but there's also no reason to
assume that shanks is stronger than me
Hawk at this point shanks asks me Hawk
very seriously if he wanted to challenge
him clearly showing that he respects me
Hawk strength and that the battle would
be a challenge for him later white beard
tells shanks that his past duel with me
hop is still fresh in the yonkos memory
white beard who held the title of the
strongest man in the world was impressed
and can't forget the duel between these
two clearly this implies that it was a
great duel of two closely matched
individuals otherwise if the gap was too
big it would be boring and over quickly
however since me Hawk got the undisputed
title of greatest swordsman in the world
it stands to reason that he bested
shanks in the past more on this later
but for now let's jump to the marine
forward battle everyone pays attention
when me Hawk is about to attack even
though they're surrounded by a
battlefield of strong fighters Toshiki
points out that me hawks blade is one of
only 12 supreme grade swords me Hawk
releases one of his air slashes at white
beard from far away
observers mentioned that me hot slash is
known as the most powerful slash in the
world it cuts straight through the
ground until the 3rd division commander
of the white beard pirates diamond jozu
stops it yes diamond is one of the
strongest materials in the world and
jozu probably has one of the best
defenses in all of one piece but this
instance Illustrated that me Hawk is not
all-powerful not even he at the very
least from that distance can cut
everything when Luffy runs into me Hawk
on the battle
field luffy says to himself that he
doesn't have time to fight someone
that's strong since he has to hurry to
ace for luffy who jumped into fights
with so many powerful people over the
course of his journey without thinking
this is a big compliment from a great
distance
amid the busy battlefield me hawks hawk
eyes and observation haki let him easily
track a gear to luffy running as fast as
he can me hawk hits him with an air
slash and closes the distance between
them in a heartbeat showing that his aim
is amazing and that he's insanely fast
the short clash between them is very
noteworthy because of how luffy behaves
usually he launches his gumgum attacks
without a second thought
but in this case luffy stops his gumgum
jet because he senses that me hawk would
have cut off his hands if he had
attacked luffy is rattled and barely
dodges a slash as an unintended
byproduct of his attack me Hawk happens
to cut a mountain sized iceberg Luffy is
only saved because the 5th division
commander of the white beard pirates and
greatest swordsman within the white
beard pirates flower sword Vista starts
clashing with me hawk as luffy's
escaping me hawk thinks to himself that
it's not luffy's powers or techniques
he possesses some quality that makes
people want to help him and that is the
most formidable power of all me hawk
can't help but acknowledge vistas skill
and reputation after clashing for a bit
me Hawk tells Vista that they should
settle things later and Vista agrees me
Hawk didn't really had beef with Vista
and this son needed to help his crew and
rush into the plaza so they stopped I
have no doubt that me Hawk would have
won but this is something you'll notice
in one piece even stronger characters
usually can't just kill other strong
characters in a second the fights tend
to last long like when cools on in a
kind new fought for ten days before a
kind of one this is something that keeps
things interesting and keeps someone
like ultra instant Goku from one
shotting everyone me Hawk and Vista are
two of the greatest swordsman in the
world and in the world of one piece it
takes time to win such a battle although
it should be kept in mind that me Hawk
didn't break a sweat or get hurt
throughout the battle at marine fort
even though there were such powerful
fighters present at one point me Hawk
takes
das bones effortlessly with a cut but
crocodile clashes with me hak soo da
Luffy can escape a second time when
shank shows up me Hawk is fine unscathed
but he starts to leave explaining that
he agreed to fight white beard but he
never agreed to fight red haired shanks
some people have suggested that me Hawk
leaves because shanks is too strong and
he's intimidated but there's no evidence
for that in my view shanks is his friend
and he doesn't want to take the
government side over his during the time
skip Zorro who wants to become the
greatest swordsman one day chooses to
spend his time being trained by me Hawk
me Hawk Todd Zorro how to infuse his
blades with hockey and he taught him
that every Nick on a sword is a mark of
shame and all those or Oh
is a great swordsman he still admits
that he's nowhere near me Hawks level
even after training under him for two
years
furthermore me Hawk clearly has a strong
will since he wasn't affected by Luffy's
conqueror haki at marine fort and he
never fell for Bowa Hancock's charms
thus clearly there is a reason me Hawk
is acknowledged to be the strongest
swordsman and his sword slash is said to
be the most powerful in the world in
marine Ford we saw that he wasn't just
one shotting powerful opponents but that
seems to be the way one piece goes we've
also never seen me Hawk go all out
he was never pushed into a corner
sweating and bleeding while fighting for
survival even a marine Ford he didn't
break a sweat or receive injuries
he's been associated with Yong Co in
different ways throughout the series
he owns a supreme grade blade while
white beard owned another that was
attached to his naginata those are the
only two supreme grade blades we've seen
so far
furthermore me Hawk was shanks his rival
and they dueled in the past although I
think they were close me Hawks title
suggests that he had the better of
shanks back then people suggest that
shanks is stronger now than he was back
then but then they don't take into
account that me Hawk could have gotten
significantly stronger too over time
just because me Hawk is not a young code
that doesn't mean that a miyako is
automatically stronger than him me Hawk
has no interest in being a Yong chol
Yong ko are supposed to be the powerful
captains of the strongest pirate crews
but me Hawk travels alone and
has no desire for a crew I am of the
opinion after all we've seen that mihawk
is not below yong-chol level in terms of
strength and there is an argument to be
made that he could be stronger than
shanks one on one they could be close
and the match could last for days
but I think that mihawk would still come
out on top
shanks obviously hasn't gotten weaker
since he lost his arm
that was me Hawk just messing with him
but anyone who assumes that shanks has
grown in power should assume that me ha
could have grown in power too some
people suggest that shanks wasn't using
haki when he fought me hawk but that
makes no sense to me since we always see
swordsmen using haki in their sword
fights in one piece in fact mastery of
hockey is essential if you ever want to
be the strongest swordsman furthermore
we've also seen Tommy Hawk can resist
conquerors haki after all there is a
reason that this dude feels comfortable
enough to travel across the dangerous
seas alone on the tiniest boat you've
ever seen no one out there not an
admiral or yong-chol could one shot me
hawk the best they could hope for is a
prolonged battle so most people would
simply steer clear of him however as
I've said in previous videos I think if
you factor in the strength of shanks is
crew on top of his own
then shanks is a much more dangerous
pirate than me hawk and that's why he
deserves the title of Yong chol more
when me hawk said people wanting to help
you is the most dangerous power of all
that was also significant just think
about how Luffy would be dead right now
if Nico Robin hadn't saved him Luffy was
beaten by crocodile multiple times but
people want to help him or crocodiles
own people were willing to betray him
that made the difference if it was a
simple battle to the death Luffy would
be dead right now so the fact that
shanks has a powerful crew that wants to
help him and that he is able to
influence people like Kaito Marco to
Phoenix and San Goku makes him very
dangerous even though that doesn't
necessarily factor in when we're talking
about one-on-one fights to the death but
make sure let me know what you think
about all of this in the comments below
even though we didn't see me hawk
one-shotting strong characters I'm
marine Ford I still think he's the uncle
level when it comes to one-on-one fights
one piece is fun precisely because it's
not
black-and-white and strong characters
can't just embarrass one another in a
matter of seconds that's also why videos
like this one are so much fun to make if
you did enjoy this video and want to
keep them coming
show one piece some love by smashing
that like button and sharing this video
remember if we can get five thousand
likes
I repeat five thousand likes on this
video I'll get started on the next
strengths video ASAP if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future one piece videos
lastly the YouTube rates have
significantly dropped recently so the
help and support we're getting from our
anime opera patrons is now more
important than ever a special thank you
goes to our patrons over on patreon who
help us survive YouTube issues and who
helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost I want to
thank the legends acknowledged by Lord
Twigg Oh himself
baby ray and Efrain a-and the one tier
patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans Steven and Radha a Lola not them
though world stealers the school bus
Theisen Kirino acquire respect in
Pattaya hefa and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson kings
I'll just Anatole Kazan Sookie angel
Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan Kapoor
Crickett EXPEED Ted no Ted
Joel turtle Stanton barry gucci alicia
actor animal 69 jessica calif on he no
commie and water Bonnie parks deci D
Emperor Taku JCC waka and the coach
thank you all so much if you enjoy our
work you can support more of it by going
over to patreon comm anime up lore and
becoming a patron today for as little as
$1 if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course
dank memes so check out patreon comments
on 10 that way if you prefer whichever
way you choose to support us you can get
the same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see us space
Cowboys
[Music]